if somebody was gonna make
the new espn for for for lack of a
better kind of simple easy comp
like what would that look like would
that be a cable channel running 24 hours
showing live games having a bunch of
people talking about trades all day if
that's not resonating with this next
generation who we talked talked about
was different we followed kind of these
athletes right before the
they became pro on their journey
we didn't really do a lot of criticism
we never ranked them we never talked
about trades we never trashed athletes
wow
we just had a different perspective that
i think we learned from partnering with
our audience that really resonated with
them
[Music]
i am so pumped to welcome to yankspeaks
my friend
uh co-founder and ceo of overtime dan
porter dan welcome
thanks for having me andrew dan we go
way back you and i uh you've had an
incredible career the thing that people
might have had uh on their phones that
that they'd be most familiar with is
probably draw something
if they remember draw something
you were the man behind draw something
uh which was uh a phenomenon you know
tens of millions of people were uh
teaming up with their friends to to play
um
we but you and i were
uh colleagues adventure for america when
i was trying to enlist you to help
because you were the first president of
teach for america and i know there must
be a lot of people here who uh know
tfairs or have been part of teach for
america
and that was back in like the early 90s
how the heck does one become the first
president of teach for america
yes so before we made draw something we
were just a scrappy mobile games company
and i think um mary park introduced us
and you came to our office on crosby
street which was jammed full of people
and said you had this idea that you
wanted to do
like teach for america but for
entrepreneurship and i was like i don't
know who this guy is but it sounds like
a terrible idea and you should never do
it uh and then you prove me totally
wrong and so i joined the board and we
worked there for three years
um but
yeah i mean it's a crazy journey i uh i
graduated from college i didn't know
what i wanted to do i ended up kind of
working in the music industry briefly
because i had been a professional
musician and then had a friend uh from
college who was early at teach for
america and in between that time i had
actually taught public school in
brooklyn
un unrelated to teach for america just
was kind of like in my early 20s
bouncing around looking for something to
do
uh that i thought would be interesting
and have some meaning uh and he said you
should come work with us at teach for
america i mean you've already taught for
a year and i was thinking well one year
is really not very much teaching
but i joined and
uh did a little bit of everything
because in the beginning and i'm sure it
was like that with vfa everybody kind of
did a little bit of everything and
eventually i kind of found my way in the
recruitment and selection side and ended
up building the whole initial
recruitment process
uh and really it was my first taste of
entrepreneurship because we could do
what we wanted and we decided we wanted
to make people write their essay in
person in front of us because we felt
like people
and we were successful and we had the
kind of biggest
application pool ever and i had done a
bunch of things and i think at that time
wendy kind of wanted to
be more chairperson and and do a bunch
of other things and potentially launch
offshoots of teach for america
uh and i was lucky enough to be chosen
to be the president of teach for america
four years into my journey there wow so
wendy copp uh the founder of teach from
america um
and
uh
did you guys know each other from school
is that right i think you guys both went
to the same college
we both went to princeton i i knew who
she was uh because she uh
dated somebody who was in my eating club
but i i wasn't friends with her i i
didn't really know her um and it's funny
i was thinking about wendy today because
i give her a lot of credit for this kind
of
idea this thing that she said early on
that she probably doesn't even know how
much i
influenced me and a lot of other people
which was in the very beginning of teach
for america i remember that
the kind of
funders or investors if you want to call
them that
said you know why don't you take 50
people into teach for america and figure
out if it's going to work and work out
the kinks and wendy said if we take 50
people nobody will ever care about teach
for america and so we took 500 people
and it was crazy but ultimately she was
right and even with 500 people people
didn't really know or care and i think
in 92 or 93 there was a new york times
article and people started to figure it
out but for years i would tell people i
had work to teach for america and they
didn't know what it was but i think you
know in a way wendy was right like she
made a big bet and she had to do
something that people would care about
and you know flash forward to what you
were saying like i'm
as part of overtime we're starting our
own basketball league and people's like
oh you could take three or four
athletes and figure it out and in the
back of my head is like is anybody gonna
care unless we take 25 athletes and try
to figure it out so i think that kind of
mantra and that approach has had a big
influence on me throughout my career
well certainly teach for america is the
big easiest example of a non-profit that
is
reach scale touched at this point i
would say millions of lives
um and for me when i started venture for
america the first thing i did was buy
wendy's book
about how she started teaching for
america um so if you're an aspiring
entrepreneur out there uh books are good
if you can find uh an entrepreneur who
did something similar and then you read
their book you'll get a lot from it um
dan porter shows up in that book and so
then i i
when i was offered an introduction to i
was like oh my gosh like one of the
people that built this thing like i
totally want to to meet you and find out
more um i do remember how dubious you
were in that first meeting but then
but then and that's another lesson for
any aspiring entrepreneur out there is
that look someone can not be into it
initially but if you do the work and uh
you demonstrate that you're serious and
are making progress that they can come
back around so
you know like no isn't always no no i'm
not sure you actually said the word no
but i think you might have said this is
a terrible idea yeah
i probably did but but i will say i
loved being on the venture for america
board because
there were kind of pattern recognitions
like we made so many mistakes early on
in teach for america because we just
didn't know when we didn't have a
blueprint and i remember we were talking
about supporting the core members of vfa
and various cohorts and should you have
support at the local level or the
national level and you know there were
lots of things where there were other
people on the board who added more value
than i did but there were definitely
things where i was like oh my god we
dealt with that and we made mistakes so
we figured that out and i was like very
excited to raise my hand and say like i
i can tell you from experience this is
this is something that we should do at
vfa without having to overthink it and
you should learn from our mistakes
and anytime you spoke everyone just
listened because you had the most direct
experience of any of us it was like dad
said that we should look at it this way
so we should probably do what he says
uh so after teach for america so at this
point you're in like mid to late 20s and
then you pivot to a business career and
you work for richard branson who now i
think might be the first person to go
into space uh commercially
just honestly i mean i i will say as an
aside like
i remember that when i worked at virgin
which was
i think 15 years ago we had to bring
your kids to work day like people used
to love to do that and i remember
because in the picture my kids are
little and now you know one of my kids
is a college graduate and there's a
model of the virgin galactic
kind of ship and everything else like
that so it seems like it's like we're
just going to space but 15 years ago we
work on virgin galactic and there were
little models of spaceship like so it's
been so long it feels compressed but um
it's been a very very long journey and
so i don't know what is he 70 now so he
was my age he was 55 when he started
thinking about wanting to do that
there's another lesson there gosh
uh i met richard briefly
uh and even my brief contact with him
led me to think that he is one of the
more sane
moguls
he actually seemed very down to earth
and with it which is a funny uh
adjective to use for someone who
literally just went into space but
[Laughter]
but he struck me as like a really
positive uh effusive leader um did you
have that kind of experience with him
like how closely did you work with him
yeah i think every every kind of
ceo or founder has a different skill set
i would say
for richard's he's very charismatic
he's very interpersonally warm i
remember we went on
one of the early things that i did is we
went on a trip to toronto where virgin
mobile had you know their office and
that was kind of the
cell phone provider that eventually
sprint bought
and uh he went and he talked to
essentially the call center at the at
the virgin mobile place so it was a
bunch of people who were you know
working in customer support
and he was so funny and approachable and
warm that like literally like they
wanted to go up and hug him afterwards
and you've got a hug he kind of has a
teddy bear
yeah you've got people who lead by fear
you've got people who are brilliant but
interpersonally not strong you've got
people who are amazing at numbers you
know you've got people who are
engineering geniuses and his was just
this kind of natural people skill and
charisma
um that you would ultimately see
like a real ability i think to put
people at ease
and he always loved kind of his his
marketing approach was stunts right he
had all those kind of virgin atlantic
versus you know
british airways types of stunts and
stuff like that i think he was the
original pre-internet person
you know who really understood how you
could make a splash and i think at one
point we were gonna launch a casino
in vegas or a hotel maybe in vegas and
he agreed to bungee cord off the top of
the building that we were going to turn
into and i mean he had to be in his 60s
at that point i think he actually
bounced into the side of the building
and ripped up his pants and stuff like
that
there's zero chance that i would ever
personally do that but that was like
part of his i think part of his energy
and his up for everything and you know
as as any
leader you you hope that that kind of
then inspires all the people who work
kind of
all throughout your organization to take
that type of mindset too
he did have a real magnetism to him when
i when i met him um and it was fun
experiencing it
so you went from virgin
was that straight then to omg pop and i
remember meeting you and the crowd of
people in crosby street who were working
on the games and when i came and visited
you guys hadn't come up with draw
something yet like i and that there was
a sense that you really had uh
struck
gold or had lightning in a bottle or
whatever metaphor you want to use where
draw something was concerned um
did that
level of virality and success take you
by surprise uh
when it happened
uh it did i i would say that
so so to go back one thing kind of when
i left
almost nine years working in
non-profit and education i decided i
told my wife jokingly that i wanted to
be a capitalist uh it was really hard to
make that transition
um and i'm sure there are people
who are watching or listening who may
have experienced that because i think
that the view was like oh you worked a
non-profit like you don't know anything
about money you've ripped genes you have
some save the world mentality when in
fact you know there's a in the venn
diagram there's a tremendous number of
attributes where there's overlap with
for-profit and i thought even about
going to business school because i just
couldn't get people to kind of
take it
seriously and it was really frustrating
and i look i had been the president
teach for america i'd managed all of
those people
uh and i ended up kind of
you know talking my way into a small
investment banking firm where i didn't
know anything about finance and doing
that for two years and then moving to
the west coast and with one of my
college roommates
being involved in the start of ticket
web which was sold the first concert
tickets on the internet kind of while
ticketmaster was still selling them via
kind of telephone and going to tower
records and eventually we turned that
into a business and sold that to
uh ticketmaster for 40 million dollars
and
all of a sudden like nobody ever asked
me you know why are you incompetent
because you worked at non-profit before
uh so
that was like that was kind of my
transition point and from there i kind
of ended up kind of coming back
eventually working for richard and while
i was working at virgin
there was this movement to say
virgin started out and it was really
cool because richard owned a record
label like you know rock and roll was
cool and then he signed janet jackson
and then he did all these things and i
think there was a whole nother
generation that kind of forgot what was
cool about virgin um because they were
just too young for when the music was
part of the business and so i launched
all these music festivals uh in 2005
2006 in the united states and canada and
then i started kind of reading at that
time you know people would say the video
game industry is bigger than the film
industry it's bigger than the music
industry and i just started thinking
like oh my god is video games like the
new rock and roll is that the thing
everyone's gonna do and kind of through
luck i ended up uh meeting and being
introduced to charles foreman who was
the original founder of omg pop at that
time it was called i'm in like with you
and i just didn't understand anything
that he was saying i didn't understand
his website and i was like oh this is
probably what they mean and this is the
future so when i signed on you know
there was there were seven people it was
a small office that was above
a combination taco bell dunkin donuts so
whatever smell you had could be changed
in the room and there was actually no
cell service in the little office on on
i think 36th street and so immediately
we needed to raise money but i couldn't
take any calls from investors because we
couldn't get cell service in the little
office so i would go downstairs when it
was freezing cold and like try to call
people and eventually you know charles
very talented and he saw a lot of
openings that other people hadn't seen
um but we hit this point that's very
interesting in
startups where
we were successful
like we had over a million users but we
weren't like insanely successful so we
didn't fail like we had loyal users we
had me i mean four to five hours what
they called time on site
um
but we weren't a billion dollar business
we were kind of stuck in the middle um
and that's tough because you're not
things aren't going badly but you're not
also having explosive growth
uh and all of a sudden farmville came
out
and
zynga figured out some way to kind of
crack facebook and they had explosive
growth and if we had one two three
million users they had a hundred million
users
um
and then
we kind of missed that like we weren't
paying attention to facebook style games
it wasn't what we did
um and then all of a sudden the iphone
came out and we we didn't make angry
birds and we didn't make fruit ninja we
didn't make any of those early games and
so everyone was like wow you guys were
on the web and you missed facebook and
you missed mobile um but the reality is
is like you can still make them a game
on mobile like there's no missing mobile
like that there's so much change and
obviously the iphone's changed so much
um and so
we kind of took a big shot and made this
game but we were making four other games
at the same time as we made draw
something so we really had no idea it
was it was our own ip because we had
made a web version and ultimately a
facebook version of the of the same game
was called draw my thing which we
thought was a little risque so we
simplified it for uh for for the app
store and uh we just didn't have any
idea and when we released the game
um it kind of climbed the charts and
then it fell down the charts and so we
got to like 25 on the app store and we
were like well i guess that was our big
shot
um and then two of our software
developers
uh chris and and jason said we they we
think there might be something wrong
with the game and they came into the
office on a friday and they didn't leave
till monday
um and they reconfigured the entire back
end of the game and what had happened
was the game was actually enormously
popular but we had made some mistakes in
in this development of software was just
crashing for everyone and the second
that they kind of fixed that and we got
that built in the app store the game
just blew up and i think at its height
it was you know
millions of downloads per day like we
had a little graph that showed how many
people were downloading it and the
numbers would go so fast that it was
basically broken
um and i remember the other thing was
everyone was like we've got to get some
influencers to support the game and
somebody's like oh i know somebody who
plays pro football and i have a friend
who does this and i was 100 unsuccessful
at reaching any influencer to talk about
the game but what ended up happening was
everybody like
the cast of the jersey shore miley cyrus
ryan seacrest like these people were
playing the game anyway because it was
in the app store and they all started
tweeting about it talking about it on
facebook and instagram people were like
your influencer strategy is amazing i
was like i wish i had anything to do
with that but it was you're like yes it
is
it just kind of crossed over into
culture and that that that kind of that
kind of amplified it and i think at its
height i don't know 24 25 million people
a day
uh were were playing the game and it was
just it was gigantic it was a total
whirlwind and the other story is i
remember the year before we had gone to
the game developer conference in san
francisco which is you know essentially
a trade show for game developers um
nobody really cared about us nobody knew
who we were
um and you know whatever i sat in the
back and listened to successful people
talk about how to be successful in games
and as we went this time the game had
started blown up and like everybody was
talking about us people were coming up
to me and it was so surreal within the
course of 12 months to be like somebody
who was in the audience and then all of
a sudden to walk in and people were like
oh that's those those guys from omg pop
like it is
i just i i don't think we expected it
and i think that but it was fun and it
was great and everybody wanted to meet
with us and they wanted to know what the
special sauce was and i'm not even sure
any of us could tell you what the
special sauce is like things came
together and we made a good game based a
great game based on everything we had
learned in the you know making all these
other games but it was a really it was a
very surreal journey i'm sure
well there's another lesson there which
is how many games do you think that your
team had worked on prior to draw
something becoming a hit because it
sounds like
i think 44 games we had made before that
hit
yeah so game number 45 ended up being
the the thing that uh struck gold um and
i've had that experience too of being in
a conference uh 12 months ago when uh no
one cares about you and then 12 months
later like where uh everyone tries to
talk to you on the presidential
it's like i showed up to
iowa 2018 and it was like who the heck
is that guy and then like by the time
2019 rolled around uh you know
like i had a lot of energy around me um
so that that's a really fun somewhat
surreal experience
yeah the thing the thing i'll say also
like that's amazing about the game
business
is and i think i took some way it's like
a startup within a startup right every
game is like making a mini startup you
know is it how are you going to launch
who's going to use it is it going to hit
or not and that idea of
being in a
in a startup where like you're trying to
do one thing
um and maybe it hits or isn't
is amazing but like being in a startup
where you're launching all these kind of
mini startups these mini aspects of it
out of there um
is really is is incredibly exciting and
even if you think about where we are now
with overtime you know we're on the
media side we have this league you know
we're we're about to do a bunch of stuff
in the name image likeness like we're
constantly launching stuff and i think i
i really got energized and almost
learned a lot about that from being in
the game business
so there must have been any number of
games where you thought to yourself ooh
i've got a really great feeling about
this one game number 17
is is the one and then it goes nowhere
um like did you have your heart broken
any number of times where you were like
oh i've got a special feeling about this
one and then does that end up um uh
hardening you in a positive way where
like you know you were able to cut your
losses even on projects that you had
high hopes for
it's a good question i look we we made
games games that i had nothing to do
with that
that uh charles drew and all these
talented game developers made at omg pop
that were so
fun
like literally i would play them my kids
would play them i mean we had this game
baluno that was insanely fun
and the challenge is there's there's two
aspects to anything essentially
that you make as a startup
and one is essentially that thing you're
making
we'll call it content or product and the
other is essentially distribution and
and in the case of those like we made
these fun games
but there was no natural form of
distribution like we could have done
paid marketing for them but there was
nothing that drove them to be any bigger
we would drop them into the million
people on our site and they'd be like
this the greatest game i've ever seen
but the million and first person would
never see it
um
and so you're constantly start to think
about how do i take the distribution and
the marketing part of of my game and how
do i put it actually into my product you
know how do i make something that's not
only fun but by nature shareable and and
farmville actually was a very good
example of that early on it was a little
heavy-handed but there were things you
couldn't do unless you invited your
friends on facebook to do them and and
by nature the distribution was in that
and so when we made you know draw
something and we knew that
we wanted you to be able to play with
your friends and we wanted it to be
distributed and early on i remember even
before it blew up friends of mine would
say
people i haven't like talked to in five
years are like hitting me up on g chat
and on aim and telling me have you seen
this game will you play it with me and
i knew that i knew the game was fun but
then you saw that the natural
distribution
was was in there and so as i said before
whether it was people talking about it
on social or whatever we always had we
had a lot of fun games but we had never
really cracked into what the natural
distribution cycle was and when those
two came together that that was really
that that was gold
so at at this point then uh
the company is the hottest uh company
around and uh you get bought by zynga
uh and then you serve as a
zynga executive for a period um no you
you'd already been part of successful
acquisitions but i feel like that one
was still a very big deal um because
that this was at the peak of uh the
market and zynga was one of the hottest
companies around at the time
yeah so
uh
it was it was known also because i think
they closed the deal in nine days so
they had a day law firm and a night law
firm
so that they could work 24 hours
i am not doing part of this
very very high urgency
on doing the deal and and look i mean
there are a lot of reasons
that companies get bought and companies
get sold
and not only were we incredibly
successful at that time
but our user base was so big
that every other player zynga electronic
arts they were actually seeing their
user numbers go down because users were
stopping playing other games and coming
to play our game
and so
i i always i always try to tell the
people i work with now like
companies buy other companies you you
sit there and you think my company is
amazing like people should buy it
because we we're awesome and the
rationale for other companies are things
you don't understand either in the case
of a zynga like they needed to
aggressively move from essentially
web-based games to mobile games
in the case of uh on electronic arts
they needed to move from kind of console
games to casual games like they all had
pressures as companies and on the market
we had we were actually had been offered
more money by two japanese game
companies that were looking to crack
into the united states so they all had
different rationales it didn't mean that
our game and our company wasn't awesome
but they had different things things
driving them and it was a very
competitive process
um and then it happened rather quickly
and and at the time that we sold
we also had term sheets to raise you
know 50 to 100 million dollars and build
out a really big business from there
which was also interesting and i
remember i walked into the conference
room with a couple of the key guys who
had been there for four or five years
you know since
we were you know in that small seven
person office and i said hey we have
this offer to sell this comp to buy the
company and we also have offer to keep
going and build something bigger what do
you guys want to do and they were like
we've been at this for five years like
we we don't have a ton of money like we
we want to sell like we we want to a be
able to capitalize on everything and be
like we just kind of want to make games
like
because if you take the 50 million
dollars now you've got hr and you've got
legal and you've got all of these other
things why not use all the things our
partner has
and we can just be in the place to do
what we do best we can still be a 40 50
person company we don't want to be a 500
person company to do that and
even though i was the ceo and then there
was a board above me it was clear that
that was the will of the people um and
that that was really important to me and
so that's what we ended up doing oh
there's another important lesson there
too because i think a lot of ceos would
have been like huh like what do i think
[Laughter]
uh but the i mean the life's blood of
that kind of company is that people uh
creating
and you know if they
uh wanted to sell then i agree with you
uh you know i'm sure it was the right
thing to do so
you started your career as a school
teacher and then you worked in a
nonprofit um and you just talked about
how you had a really hard time breaking
in you you
uh talked your way into a business
position and then you moved out west
with a friend and started a company
that's like a very very dramatic
decision uh at that point uh you know
was there
um
was there a lot of uh struggle when you
and your friend were living out west
trying to make a new company work like
and and one of the things i love talking
about is how hard it is to start a
company just you know in general um my
first company did not work out it was a
flop um and so i ended up working at
another startup um when you and your
friend moved out west was that uh
was that something that
uh felt like it was going to work the
whole time or were there times when you
were like we don't know what we're doing
so
he he actually already lived in the bay
area so i moved out to join him i was
actually married already to melanie and
i had
uh a baby
um
so
and but that you know it was him and me
and a couple of other people
um
it was a big
it was a big
risk and
we were small and
every deal like when you're small is
potentially transformative and then it
turns out that it's not transformative
and you're kind of on to the next deal
but i i think that my
my mindset was always
not will it work but like
how do we keep moving so
that we make it work like we've been
given this
hand which is maybe somebody's giving us
a little bit of money we have some
software we have a market opportunity
and
if it doesn't work maybe it's because we
just had our head in the sand and we
didn't move fast enough to figure out
where those opportunities are and and
and it's funny because look we were in
essentially the concert ticketing
business and we made a couple of
strategic decisions that were really
smart you know there were there i think
there were four competitors in the
market
and they immediately tried to sign up
people all over the united states we
actually only signed up people in the
san francisco area and so we were highly
concentrated in a way we were much
smaller than our competitors and they
were actually raising more money
but our ability to essentially support
and learn from those customers was very
high because anybody could essentially
drive
you know there in 20 minutes and figure
it out um and we actually got critical
mass and i remember we came back to new
york and they were like oh you were
those guys who are huge in in san
francisco everybody knows about you and
everyone else was struggling to support
you know somebody in chicago and
somebody else and and so eventually we
we we kind of grew there um and i
remember second thing is that we got
approached by a golf company and they
said this is like selling tickets is
like tee times and we were like oh golf
is huge you know we should really build
a bigger business here and support tea
times and you know
really take advantage of everything our
software could do
and we ultimately ended up not doing
that and i think staying
focused but like they're all a product
of a lot of small
decisions
and ultimately you just have to make a
majority right
decisions um of those but there's a lot
of up and downs you know my
the person
with whom i you know i was involved in
starting the company was my college
roommate for three years we got along
then we didn't get along and you don't
know the company and then oh no so
there's like all kinds of stuff that
that ends up uh that ends up happening
along the process
um
but i knew like whatever i had to i'd
been dealt a hand and i had to make as
much of that hand as i could and that to
me like there were no there's no option
of of not being successful i was just
like we are just going to figure this
out and i know that probably sounds kind
of
wimpy or lame but i was just like
you know
it's it's it's on us if we fail
to make something that people like it's
because we didn't do a good enough job
listening to people
[Music]
so how old were you at this time it
sounds like you're a newlywed uh i was
uh
i was 32 33.
now i was 31 when i became the head of
uh company
and i had the same attitude which is
like i'm gonna make this work and in
part because when you're at that stage i
had in my case i'd started a company
that flopped when i was 25 and then
worked for a series of companies
including with our mutual friend mary
park
that that didn't succeed
and so
by the time i was 31 and the head of a
company
i thought i am going to make this work
like there's no
choice but to make this work
and we had things to work with we had
tools to your point um and so you made
decisions
and as long as you made more good
decisions than bad but there's a very
important lesson in what you're
describing which is it sounds like you
did something um unusual in the market
at the time which was to focus on a
particular region and then nail it to a
point where you had high density and
probably i assume like good word of
mouth and reputation
in that market
and that's going to be valuable in just
about any context like if you've
captured a market maybe it's not as
enormous as the markets that other
people are chasing
but someone's going to want to to
take advantage of what you've built
and in your case
like ticket web was bought not was it
bought by ticketmaster who was it bought
by it was bought by ticketmaster
uh look at that so ticketmaster then
eventually it's like oh wow these guys
have figured it out um how many years
did that process take
uh
it it took we sold in may of 2000 so it
took about two and a half years
and and and i'll say i'll say yeah
two things about it one is that
the non-profit background kind of became
my secret weapon because nonprofits are
very oriented on solving a problem
um and and that's why like you know when
you focus and you set out for vfa we're
going to create x number of jobs or
whatever you have a very driving focus
and so when you know
when i was involved with ticket web we
were like
we're the little guy
the company started like almost every
single ticketing company started because
somebody bought a ticket from
ticketmaster and they were like what is
this crazy fee at the end of the ticket
and they got
very you know upset about it and i
remember that yeah yeah so so there was
this idea that like we were
democratizing ticketing and we weren't
going to have these crazy fees and we
were for the people
um and that idea it was very motivating
it attracted employees it kept employees
focused but it wasn't dissimilar to
almost like how you think about your
mission as a non-profit and for me that
was a very natural transition and and
that became
uh
you know a skill set that i had
developed in non-profit that made a lot
of sense uh in the for-profit space and
then when ticketmaster was interested in
buying the company
a lot of companies were going public
because it was the dot-com boom right so
you'd have these companies that made
zero dollars and went public and were
worth tons of money and i remember i
went and i met with
three different investment banks that
took all these companies public i don't
think any of them exist anymore
and they were telling me how they were
gonna take ticket went public and
everything else like that
and in my heart of hearts i was like i
don't think we're ever going to be
that giant of a company like
ticketmaster's really big and i think we
have a really amazing
niche that we're in
but i can't tell you that i believe
we're a multi-billion dollar public
company and and their message was like
everybody we take public is a billion
dollar public company because you know
the markets are so crazy i was just like
i just don't i can't do this honestly
um because i'm not really sure that
that's the right end game whereas i knew
that as soon as bigger companies were
interested that made a lot of sense you
know they served big venues we served
small venues they were still using
traditional ticketing systems that built
up the ticket we were using the internet
um and so
in theory we probably could have made a
lot more money if we had gone public
been worth billions of dollars sold all
of our shares and then eventually
crashed down but it just didn't it
didn't seem
i want to say ethical it just didn't it
i just didn't really see the big picture
there and so we ended up you know there
a bunch of these companies that were
public were interested and we ended up
selling to ticketmaster who was
obviously the biggest and most
well-known
[Music]
so now you have a new mission
which is to build a future of sports
media over time you bro bring it back to
the people talking about democratizing
tickets democratizing entertainment now
it's democratizing sports media and the
way the talent interacts with it so you
had a vantage point where you were
looking at a lot of different businesses
and uh esports and and and other things
and then you just had to throw down on
over time i remember even when you
started over time i was like yeah that's
a great idea but uh but
um you know you've built something
enormous i think you're getting over a
billion views on months uh there are
probably a lot of people that are
watching this we're like oh yeah i love
overtime so tell us about the mission of
overtime and then its founding
uh
and what's happened since because it's
one of the most exciting growth stories
in all of sports and media
uh well well i appreciate it and you
know it was it was all those stories you
told me about the hoopin you did while
you were in law school uh
yes
the inspiration for overtime right here
um
so i i had been uh working at endeavour
which is a global talent agency which
then was called william morris endeavor
uh and
we had bought img which was another
three letter but a big sports media
company so so i found myself kind of
working in digital and then essentially
working in sports
and in about 2013 2014 there was a
narrative that was kind of inside of
sports but wasn't really in the press as
much and that narrative was we're
concerned about the next generation of
viewers and sports fans and why are we
concerned
number one they're not watching three
hour live games
they're not watching television
they have an in incredible
alternatives for their time
social media video games watching
netflix on demand watching game of
thrones
um and
and the average age i think of almost
every sport was somewhere of the viewer
was somewhere between mid 40s to mid 60s
and so
you know being a being the digital guy i
would go and i would talk to
different sports entities in in the us
and outside of the us and they'd say we
got to get the young viewer we need the
young viewer back and and
uh and there were other trends you know
i think you see
in the nba that people almost become
more player loyal than team loyal like
they'll if they love lebron they'll
follow lebron from team to team versus
being a die-hard fan of x or you see
more people who are fans of teams that
have no correlation to the city that
they grew up in because they discovered
them playing madden or 2k or they they
had some other relationship or
i just love this guy you know it's i
have a friend who's from atlanta he's a
celtics fan i'm like how are you a
celtics fan he's like i just loved ray
allen like that was my guy
um and and so they would say
dan like can you get all of these
youtube and instagram stars you
represent
to basically come to
a game a super bowl anything else like
that and bring in the younger audience
and i thought like sure but i think the
underlying
product underneath is potentially hasn't
changed quickly enough that
that's just window dressing it's not
it's not going to change
the the interest level
is going to be do it two and a half
hours long et
going to be cetera and look i mean i
watched a lot of sports when i was a kid
in the late 70s in the early 80s and it
really doesn't look that different than
it looks today
um you know there's a yellow line in
football that wasn't there but
everything else is pretty much almost
exactly the same and to me it's actually
very soothing it like brings me back to
my childhood when i hear mar valpard
talk and everything else like that but i
think for a different generation
um it just was a little out of sync and
there were other things that that were
changing i mean they had cameras on
their phones had all of these other
things around them in life that were
changing um and this wasn't really
changing and i thought sports is an
incredible vertical there's an um and so
much passion i mean you know we we feel
very passionate about our teams and the
players that we care about and live
sports is and sports in general
something with unpredictable endings all
of the time
and uh you know
this was a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to create essentially a
different platform around sports for a
different generation and it required
really understanding what this
generation wanted now it's no secret
that i'm neither millennial or gen z
um so
from my side i understood how digital
worked you know i had been essentially
running an agency that had represented
hundreds of youtubers and instagram and
many digital stars so i i had a lot of
insight uh about that i had a partner
zach
who was my co-founder who was 24 at the
time so he was more in that demographic
uh and together maybe there's another
lesson here if you're like a 24 year old
you got to find an old head like dan
porter
exactly and so i i just think we were
like if somebody was going to make the
new espn for for for lack of a better
kind of simple easy comp
like what would that look like would
that be a cable channel running 24 hours
showing live games having a bunch of
people talking about trades all day um
if that's not resonating with this next
generation um or would you use all the
social platforms would you do all these
different things and and and so that was
kind of where we started and we really
had three kind of
things that we thought would make us
special you know
number one is we built technology from
the very beginning so all of the short
form highlights especially around
basketball that you see
on overtime are captured with our own
software our own camera software which
meant that if if you were in our network
if you downloaded our software
you we would have over a thousand people
around the globe who we could send
somewhere to capture content for us it
would be immediately uploaded to the
cloud tagged we could distribute it
and that gave us a real advantage in
terms of breadth and speed like we had a
technological moat
the second is we really wanted to build
a brand we wanted people care about
overtime we sell millions of dollars of
overtime hoodies and and
and apparel and shirts and stuff like
that because people we created something
that that resonated with people and i
don't think traditionally people have
felt that way about media they don't
walk around with an espn shirt or a cnn
shirt because that's just a vehicle for
them to get information i have a cnn
shirt um there you go well
that's your employer so uh and the third
was we really wanted to build around
community i mean
you know from everything that that
you've accomplished on twitter and
elsewhere like having a strong community
is really key and so
you know we went out and i think there
were probably a hundred thousand people
who saw us in gyms in the first year
like in person with overtime shirts who
had some experience we answered a
quarter of a million direct messages a
year we really built we talked to people
in the comments we really built a strong
sense of community and those things came
together to be just a totally different
media platform which we called overtime
so what does overtime look like today
you know we have over a million
followers in in men's basketball and
women's basketball and football and
gaming and lifestyle and soccer we
publish on every social platform we have
over 50 million followers we have 50
different accounts across snap and tick
tock and twitter and instagram and
youtube that all essentially talk to
each other um and they're united by
essentially a single brand and that was
very different than
let's publish on television
you know who we talked talked about was
different we followed kind of these
athletes right before the
they became pro on their journey
we didn't really do a lot of criticism
we never ranked them we never talked
about trades we never trashed athletes
wow
we just had a different perspective that
i think we learned from partnering with
our audience that really resonated with
them
and so they might say over time and all
the characters who are on overtime
that's who we care about and you guys
care about you know you old people you
care about
who your characters are and everything
else like that and so that that became a
journey and then obviously as
people who are 17 or 18 and now 22 and
23 they kind of stay in our universe and
we're able to build big journey and then
we started obviously in the last year
adding an app launching our own league
we're about to do a ton of stuff with
name image likeness we're about to
create a whole subsidiary to focus on
sports betting like now that we've built
this brand and this community we're able
to keep branching out and and creating
entities that that make sense for what
our brand stands for at the core
well the the newsmaker recently has been
this league you speak of where you're
recruiting young basketball players that
are nationally ranked um their high
school age
uh and they're getting paid early on so
they're foregoing what i think most
people know it's like you know amateur
status i mean you know it's kind of
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i know you didn't you have a platform on
your presidential position on the other
oh yeah
athletes i mean they're talking about
like billion dollar franchises but can't
pay the talent like you know like
they're getting an education like the
whole thing was um such [ __ ] um and
now the cat's out of the bag i mean like
the the name image of like this stuff at
the college level um someone was joking
about how much money zion williamson
would have made in this one year at duke
if
we got the cut of all that money crazy
so much money um so i i am all for the
fact that you all are paying uh kids for
their talents uh you know they are the
value drivers um but the the first thing
i thought when i saw this i was like
like so you're gonna create like this
awesome high school team
and then i thought uh who are they gonna
play and from what i could tell is
they're gonna play other awesome high
school teams which is fascinating um so
what what does this leak look like
yeah so
uh let me step back one sense to say
that um part of the impetus is less
about i think people are attracted to
the idea that we're paying the players
that they're becoming professional
um and that's an obvious hook for the
story but the reality is is that
athletic development in this country
is kind of weird compared to the rest of
the world like there's no high school
sports anywhere else in the world like
messi just signed a big contract with
barcelona today right messi didn't go to
high school he didn't play d1 at duke
like everywhere else in the world
people who have a special skill get to
train for that skill and pursue that
only in the united states like do we
have this kind of high school college
sports system and only in sports right
if you're an incredible violinist you
don't go d1 for violin to kentucky
you know you go to juilliard and you do
what you do and so it became clear as
athletes
started to skip college and go play in
australia and elsewhere that there was a
real need
for
alternatives and i'm i'm not gonna tell
you that overtime elite is the only
solution i'm not even gonna tell you
that playing college is bad it's great
it's amazing for so many people i'm just
gonna say that for the benefit of people
who are enormously talented in sport
it's really good for them to have
options it's good for them to choose our
option it's good for them to choose like
they should have choice and that's the
thing that they don't have now and by
the way choice is like the most american
thing
um
and so that aspect for them was a huge
impetus and then for us we're already
covering all these players um and so the
idea that they could
essentially play in a league where we
could essentially be in partnership with
them
uh was hugely interesting so the league
is going to start with three teams and
then each year we're gonna grow until we
have five six seven eight teams we don't
want to start with you know eight teams
on day one because that's that's a lot
but we'll have three teams we have our
own venue uh in atlanta that we're
building from the ground up those teams
will play each other um and they will
also play uh other elite high school
teams in the united states and also
internationally so you know all the
teams that you know for soccer real
madrid barcelona they also actually have
basketball programs that are academy
programs are the same way pal gasol
played there luka doncic played there um
and and to step one back to get into
deep basketball you know three of the
five kind of super all-stars you know uh
this year you know giannis joel embiid
luca like they all didn't play in in the
american college system they all played
internationally uh and they developed in
these academy systems
uh which gives them almost an unfair
advantage you know when we brought our
first 10 athletes that we signed
together one of them jean montero who we
signed who's from the dominican republic
he had already been a pro he's 17 or 18
but he had played in spain for two years
and was clear in the first five minutes
that his development as a basketball
player was was way more advanced you
know we had guys who were top ranked
physically gifted incredible basketball
iq
he had he had just had a different path
of development and and his ability to
kind of look on the court and understand
what was going on was more advanced and
that's the options that we want to give
our players so they'll they'll play a
combination of internal and external i
like to call it like the champions
league right like you play kind of in
your own league and then you go and you
play teams from other leagues um and
there'll be a probably a false fall
winter season in the spring season um
and they'll compete and i don't want to
give everything away but we're gonna do
a couple things really differently the
way that fans involve are involved is
going to be really different some of our
camera stuff is going to be really
different i think we're wow a really fun
platform to do some experimentation
in you know in increasing the
you know how sports is consumed for our
audience um that is good that's harder
for any traditional league in any sport
to do because there are many
traditionalists who don't want to see a
ton of change um and so
that we're not only going to create a
dope league that's like really fun that
our audience is going to love we're
going to try to push the envelope in a
couple of things and it doesn't mean
we're going to have a five point shot
but it it means all the things that i
think surround the court the way fans
are involved the way the game is called
the way the game is filmed the way that
you know all those things happen you're
gonna see a lot of innovation from us
all available on overtime so fun and it
makes intuitive sense to me that an
athlete would develop better in a
professional style environment than if
you're like the most dominant
kid on your high school team you develop
some bad habits
yeah i think the the other thing is
right now if you're really good
at something
look if you're really good at acting or
music you tend not to go to high school
and you do what you do and they build
the education thing around you that that
just doesn't happen to be true in sport
with a couple of exceptions around the
olympics
um you know i don't think michael phelps
was sitting in 11th grade in the back of
a class for some 45-minute class like
listening to somebody drone on
um and so for us we're doing the same
thing like every person in our program
will get a high school degree they'll
get it from us we're just going to build
the education aspect around their
ability to train
um and to learn basketball it's going to
be individually
delivered and you know there's a ton of
research that shows on kind of
one-on-one instruction people learn it
two to three times the speed they do
when they sit in a large class
and there's a massive opportunity to
teach athletes and young people
about so many other things you know the
history of sport activism financial
literacy how to manage your money how to
you know what charities you should
contribute to emotional regulation
um you know anger management mental
health there's so many things like that
that we think that the people will leave
our program they'll have an elite
education they'll have an elite kind of
life skills education and they'll have
an elite basketball education and i
believe like nba teams are going to see
players like they've never seen before
wow the future of sports the future of
media the future of education maybe
i hope so
i'm so excited for you and proud of you
um so as someone who's been building the
future that the rest of us have been
experiencing like what do you see coming
down the pike either in your field or
generally i mean you're clearly way
ahead of the curve in terms of um
entertainment uh and uh and media but
and you also have kids who are uh you
know like in their uh
like early twenties uh or so i'm sure
you pick their brains all the time um
like what what's coming down the pike
that either you're excited about or
concerned about
um
i would say to me
it it's definitely interesting
that this kind of generation of of kind
of college kids and kids right out of
college
are
are the most
socially aware and active generation
that i think i've ever seen like real
pac i i teach a social entrepreneurship
class at nyu that you came and lectured
at
um
and i think that
it's so
it's so clear that they have passion
about food waste and about you know
composting and recycling and climate and
all of these things that are incredibly
diverse
so i i think that
that generation
you know
which is technologically savvy and is
very passionate about the world is going
to have a big impact there are big you
know numerically they're they're a big
generation
um
so i think there's that i think that
it's interesting to see what changes
are gonna hold over from the pandemic
about how much time we spend in the
office i like to talk about here's an
example like
i hate qr codes like i never used qr
codes i never understood them and then
as we tried to get out of the pandemic
you would go out to dinner right and
they'd be like oh we can't give you a
menu because nobody can touch anything
and so you'd hold up your phone and
you'd kind of like take a picture and
that the menu would pop up and
and that was a big revelation
now do you love qr codes
i kind of do but it's funny you know
what pops up is a pdf of the menu like
why doesn't it tell me this was ordered
two minutes ago you know this is the
most popular dish oh your friend ain't
here they like this dish like i think
there's a lot of potential innovation
around there similarly you know we're
trying to figure out is everybody going
to come back to our office i have 100
people in new york are they going to
come back three days are they going to
come back one day what is that going to
look like i have to buy all of these
pods because some people are in and some
people are zooming so i think the nature
of how we experience the world and the
nature of work kind of impacted by these
two big forces this very
socially conscious generation and then
the accelerated kind of rethink of
things like work
by the pandemic i think are gonna change
uh are gonna change a lot what doesn't
change is that there's an enormous
amount of power as you know as a
politician that is still held
by older generations there's an enormous
amount of unequal power where a small
number of people control an excess
number of senate seats
that cause us to resist change in a lot
of different ways
and i don't know where that's going
climate wise voting rights wise and
everything else like that but there's no
doubt that you know here's a generation
of people who can make you know cinema
and music with their phones right who
can create things on tick tock who can
story tell in a different way who can
learn in a different way the number of
people that work for me that never
majored in video or film that learned
editing by watching youtube videos is
astronomical and they continue to learn
that way so those are some of the things
that i look going forward to the future
that i'm interested and excited about
you know what's fun dan and you count
that in that last message of yours but
like you're you and i are now kind of
battle-hearted vets like you're in your
50s i'm in your 40s but you
instinctively when you were talking to
us now are like on the side of young
people you know
like
you're very young at heart maybe it's um
it's the way you build your career
but that's certainly something i aspire
to as well like i i i want to be someone
who helps build a bridge to the future
and then gets the [ __ ] out of the way i
think the older we get
um
the more we learn we're not supposed to
take risks and i think
the risks whether they're creative risks
or personal risks
are sometimes the things that like cause
us to move forward
um and so young people sometimes me as a
young person i didn't know i wasn't
supposed to take those risks and so i
took those risks but that that's where a
lot of that change and and
progress comes from especially in
business and and other places and so to
me that's always exciting like people
coming into the world and saying why
does it have to be this way
um
you know it's like i i think about you
know the other classic example in my
class at nyu oh i'm gonna major in
english and somebody's parent says what
are you gonna do with an english degree
be an english teacher
and i tell the students you know what
you do in life has so little to do with
your major none of you guys have any
idea what my major was it's so
irrelevant you're just here to like meet
people and learn and that's like
mind-blowing to them
um but the fact is like anything is
possible and i think ultimately young
people really um personify that kind of
belief and i get a lot of energy from
that
now
you've taken big swings at every stage
of your career down and it's something
that i think people should do more of
because like you said when we get older
it gets a little bit harder to take
those big swings i mean uh it's
something that i i try to to do as well
i try and think okay let me take on
something that if i succeed it will be
actually meaningful and impactful
i'll be proud like
as opposed to like if i succeed no one's
really going to give her [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no you i mean you've taken some big
swings too i remember when you told me
you're going to run for president and i
said of what
and you said uh of the united states and
that
that's a it's a big swing and i think
that we tend to be very
short-sighted or binary in that like
well okay andrew on for president but he
didn't become president and i think when
you
zoom back in the scheme of history
you know the impact that we'll all have
to move things forward to
inspire other people to think
differently to galvanize the way people
think about using social media to
galvanize the way people think about
politics like all of those are massive
contributions that have nothing to do
with
the end you know the end goal so if i
think about like even in the tiny world
of sports and in the tinier world of
basketball
like if we're successful at changing the
way people think about how we develop
athletes whether overtime a lead ever is
as big as the nba or not like we're all
making these kind of small contributions
to pushing it forward and
you know people on the outside get very
hung up on like well did you create a
billion dollar business or didn't you
did you win or did you lose and and in
fact just the process of doing that
um is massively beneficial to inspiring
other people to changing the narrative
to changing the way people think
well you've done more than your fair
share of that dan i'm going to close on
what you said to me after you said
president of what
but then you you said you said you know
andrew uh i i bet against you once i'm
never gonna do it again whatever you do
like i'm all in uh that that's the kind
of person you are
um so grateful to to be your friend uh
and congratulations on building really
the the future of sports and media i
can't wait to get to atlanta and watch a
game
uh i'm excited to have you there and i
will come back at you to say andrew
you're one of the most relentlessly
optimistic people i know
and i always benefited by your jolt of
optimism that like anything was possible
uh so i also appreciate you a great deal
for that um we'll get you courtside
uh with the family yes i'll put it out
to the yang gang it'll be fun at uh ote
and and and thanks for having me on the
podcast
of course all the best of the family
thanks so much dan
[Music]
you